stupid and stupid yes
[Applause]
look at me there I am on TV
happy Wednesday everyone I'm drooling so
why do companies scold while thousands
of jobs fold by now we know that the
average American Beer Drinker does not
look like this
after all we prefer our beer nuts to be
in a bowl
Anheuser-Busch hired Dylan Mulvaney to
promote Bud Light sales are now down
almost 25 percent and now the company is
even talking about redesigning the
labels here's the new label
and actually here's my suggestion
I mean let's be honest she seems like a
barrel of laughs or at least two barrels
and now another company seems to be
messing with their core audience here
you have 81 year old Martha Stewart on
the cover of this year's Sports
Illustrated Swimsuit Issue yes and I'm
just gonna say it that's not bad for 81.
no sir and she's actually a woman
you know Martha has some wrinkles but
they're not on a scrotum
[Laughter]
a rated word
Inner Pop Star Kim Petrus is also on
another SI cover and I know what you're
thinking who
exactly name recognition or any
recognition at all really doesn't matter
as long as you tick a box and this one
ticks a box or rather a package
see it's not for you it's for them the
marketing team trying to score points
with corporate do-gooders and activists
if you worry the product doesn't sell
then you're a transphobe or at least a
trans fat
So Gone are the days of classic s i you
know it was Stacks in the barber shop
and each issue was coveted like a roll
of Charmin in a chili Factory
and that swimsuit issue every year it
got passed around like a hypodermic
needle in the subway oh everybody wanted
it but it's clear those customers of the
past your uncles dads and granddads they
were just awful people they're gross
sexist bigs let's be honest and it's
time we made them pay for working hard
and fighting Wars and just being decent
people because we're such better people
now
we think crickets are better than steak
and criminals are just victims of
Oppression and of course men make better
women
these new marketing people are way
better than everyone who came before
because as Miller Lite points out those
creeps they put ladies in bikinis
women were among the very first to brew
beer ever
centuries later how did the industry pay
homage to the founding mothers of fear
they put us in bikinis
look at this wild it's time beer made it
up to women so today Miller Lite is on a
mission to clean up not just their whole
beer Industries
wow the account but the company now says
women in bikinis shouldn't be forced to
mud wrestle to sell beer
I know I agree so let's go with alfredo
sauce
but they weren't forced to do anything
they were paid and if you didn't like it
you don't have to do it that's what I
say to the interns on back shave Sunday
the Miller Lite ad premiered just weeks
before Mulvaney's Bud Light videos
popped up and they saw how that played
out so they tried to bury their own ad
like it was a former Clinton associate
they acted just like druggies flushing
down their staffs because the cops are
at the door except the cops were
actually their customers
so how did this happen well all these
nauseating lectures are now masquerading
as ads are the colleges churning out too
many useless women's study grads so they
end up in companies demanding tampons
and Men's Rooms and jock straps and the
women's
they view buyers as insects stupid gross
easily manipulated someone to be
punished not celebrated like when that
Gillette ad from a few years back
offered a caricature of masculinity
suggesting bad behavior was the norm
among men they switched their slogan
from the best a man can get to use these
to slash your wrists
you male oppressors
so why does one company after another
keep alienating their customer base
corporate execs are easily manipulated
by woke grads into doing things
antithetical to success they Embrace a
short-term virtue signal over long-term
reward if they never actually talk to
the people who buy their stuff they can
fool themselves into believing their
friends and professional peers are the
real world they can tell themselves
they're making a difference if only
those stupid customers would repent by
the way did you notice Miller Light
didn't mention their most popular ads
which included famous jocks and sports
personalities like Dick Butkus and John
Madden that's right alpha males that
appealed I know surprise to men not a
single scrawny chinless Seth Meyers
among them
and you know the Ad Agency who made that
Miller's anti-sexy screen higher nothing
but beautiful women for ads that Target
women there isn't a single homely broad
selling shampoo or makeup and that makes
sense it's like buying hair care
products from a bald person
bottom line scolding people for being
people is a lousy way to sell products
and now they're so surprised when it
actually backfires I'm sorry you could
imagine where this is all headed
all right gents let's go over the
marketing strategy for our new female
products nobody knows how to sell to a
woman like a man now Steve what's the
update on those sports bras I'm just not
sure this is gonna look good on me at
the gym
great Point Johnson what's the latest on
the nail polish well this color is very
summery and I'm more of a winter palette
excellent point any more updates on the
female products sir I was thinking I
don't know
no no no no
thank you
anyone else
uh yeah uh this maternity wear
definitely isn't agreeing with my curves
like I thought it would
I don't know what do you think uh I
think that's all for today
[Applause]
tonight yes
she's like a timing belt moves fast
keeps cool and lives in her car most of
the fox Drew crime podcast Emily
campagno
beneath that Gruff exterior is a Gruff
interior former NYPD inspector and
attorney Paul Morrow
like a Rubik's Cube she's colorful
complex and 49 years old Fox News
contributor captain
and he's damaged more men than Taylor
Swift my massive sidekick in the NWA
World Heavyweight Champion Tyrus
Emily uh in case people don't realize
you were a Oakland Raiders cheerleader
and you'd never got knifed
no no not good for you only in The
Hazing when we got jumped into the team
yes um so we were an SI fan I imagine
you read Sports Illustrated
yeah I mean I I love that stuff and and
we've talked about that I was on the in
part of the maxim online you know the
cheerleader section whatever so I I love
this and what I feel that Miller Lite
for example has gotten wrong is that
they present that you have to be an or
you know you you can only apparently to
them you can only be a brewer you dig in
the dirt or you wear bikinis and you're
feminine and you're sexual I mean I have
I have a small Family Winery too that my
dad operates I dig in the dirt and I
also wear bikinis and I love looking at
ads with women in bikinis selling beer I
have no problem with it you wear a
bikini when you're digging in the dirt
yes so for them though it's only one or
the other the um the feminine m m has to
have sneakers now she's not allowed to
have agency over her own choices to
choose to be sexual to choose to be
feminine and the problem here is that
you know it's not just the woke
corporate social media mob these
companies are actually answering to that
consumer equality index there's actually
the Human Rights Campaign that created
an entire manufacturer at a quality
index that rates these companies and
according to that score that they get
that's the value of their stock right
that's the value of whether they're
they're applauded and and put in certain
advertising bundles for employees so for
them it actually has a financial value
but what they're forgetting in all of
this is the consumer and that's why
Miller Lite and Bud light's stocks and
sales have plummeted because we hate
this give me back the women in the
bikini
thank you
I am equally outraged that that female m
m has lost its agency
you know uh Paul you and I are roughly
the same age give or take a decade
you I mean I don't want to overestimate
the decline of S.I but damn remember at
its Heyday what a great magazine it was
everybody subscribed to it everybody had
it was in every part and now it's like
nobody reads it probably social media
has something to do with the internet
but you know yeah it was a must read so
you know let's take a step back what's
the comment I always ask myself why
right it's the most important
philosopher I I'm not way you know as I
was brought up that way but sincerely I
mean if you look at the common
denominator here right all right you
know you have all of these wall
companies doing what they're doing and
you have to say to yourself guys it
doesn't work economically so why are you
doing it right right so what is the
target is really what you have to ask
yourself and it doesn't it feel like
Revenge it feels to me like some place
in the in the deep dark past some
cavemen not the woman on the head grab
the bite of hair dragged her into a cave
and all the men now are paying for that
right it's like the thing that your wife
does where she says to you you know what
you remember you said me last spring
yeah it's the equivalent of that and you
have to say to say why it has that feel
and I really feel like at this point
somebody's made the calculus that
manages in the way the traditional role
of men are in a way and the reason for
that is control we're in the way of the
complete control of the eight people on
each Coast because this is not a large
group now the 15 people total who have
decided right now yeah that this is what
we have to do we have to drink beer
from Mulvaney and nobody wants to do
that yeah but you will obey yeah and at
the end even if you don't like it you
can't talk about it and so if you do
you're a transphob or whatever it is
this week and none of us can keep up yes
it says
I said cat I always feel like it's
there's a like what Paul says a sense of
vindictiveness behind this and I even
when you know men ran advertising in the
50s and the 60s and the 70s and the 80s
and the 90s and the 2000s
yeah the good old days uh
they they didn't they weren't negative
about women I mean I know you're gonna
explode no I I it's funny that you
brought up the Gillette ad because you
inspired me to re-share the rant that I
went on when everyone was going crazy
about how men were under attack
literally every ad ever is like the
entire Beauty and fitness Industries are
just telling women they're not good
enough but they do focus groups I will
re-share that they do focus groups with
women who tell you what they want they
don't want something sold from you know
a woman that they can't aspire to be I'm
I'm gonna just re-share that but also I
thought that the Martha Stewart Sports
Illustrated cover was actually quite
thought-provoking it proved to me that
age is just a number because you look at
it and you think that woman is older
than Joe Biden
[Laughter]
like that no I don't think so
only when he has to pay
[Applause]
that was for you ah
I I mean I I guess it is inspiring too
to know that I too can look like that at
81 if I just make hundreds of millions
of dollars exactly and you need like
airbrushing machine the size of a 740. I
mean I'll be dead I'll be dead yeah I
won't make it to 80. well on that up
note tires
you're a fan oh I'm a huge fan and she's
a fan yeah she's part of my group
and uh
uh no and I've had the the pleasure of
being in in her office when I was
bodyguarding for Snoop we came on her
television show where she was cooking I
know it's not a sex story I'm sorry
it could be but she was so so kind and
so OG cool she literally said hey come
with me let me show you something again
not a sex story uh big guys we don't get
that and uh she brought me in her office
I know
it's not a sex store and I go in our
office and she clicks on the lights and
she says take a look at all my Emmys and
I was like damn she had one everywhere
and then there was pictures of all this
hot there's really attractive woman I
almost said hot chick but yeah I
apologize but hot chicks all over the
walls right and she's like that's me
look at me she was a 10 before there was
a metric system you know what I'm saying
like Raquel Welch didn't have on Martha
Street
you need to check it out there how dare
had to be there you were in your what
mid-20s so you should have checked that
out and you look around the thing and
then she said to me can you believe
someone divorced me and I remember I
cannot like she has been hot for decades
she even went to jail got prison Stripes
like there's no one cooler than Martha
Stewart so I if they I will be buying
that magazine absolutely
you know I
[Applause]
think I'll pass if I could have it
that's my all pass
sorry Snoop wait he's your hall pass
no he can do TV shows together oh okay
I'm sorry I don't know they're friends
hey oh got it I got it he would be upset
yeah but I think she's his hall pass too
but I can't confirm that James Comey
arrested that yes yeah yeah okay our
priorities are sure yes okay yeah all
right hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else